en 2010 8 24 millions de bouteilles de
beaujolais nouveau ont été vendus pas
mal me direz vous mais souvenez-vous des
années 80 en quelques jours
60 millions de bouteilles quittent le
pays beaujolais véritable ruée sur l'or
rouge en france vous avez bien entendu
60 millions de bouteilles de beaujolais
nouveau vendu en 1984
ces 2,5 fois plus qu'aujourd'hui cette
ruée vers l'or rouge était le résultat
d'une immense opération marketing unique
dans le monde du vin dès 1951
les vignerons obtiennent l'autorisation
de vendre leurs vins en primeur avant
décembre
la présentation du beaujolais nouveau
est alors fixé au 15 novembre une
nouvelle fois le beaujolais réussi sa
grande fête du 15 novembre par camion ou
par avion les primeurs se sont envolées
ou quatre coins du monde
l'opération marketing fonctionne à
merveille et elle est même fixée par
décret à tous les troisièmes jeudis du
mois de novembre dès 1985
l'opération de communication se donnent
les attraits d'une tradition culturelle
bref le marketing a été fort bien fait
le beaujolais devenu légende alors dans
les années 80 les ventes s'envolent avec
des exportations au japon aux états unis
mais le mirage de l'argent facile et
tentant et certaines dérives
apparaissent il ya des excès comme pour
tous à quel endroit n'était pas d'excès
quand les choses sont parfois un peu
trop facile mais il y a en en eux mêmes
un disque de gyroscope qui ramène à la
réalité en disant attention les gars
faut pas faire l'écho
jusqu'à présent l'allemagne et vous pas
trop tirer sur la ficelle pourtant
certains vont le faire en ajoutant des
levures artificielle ou banane ou
framboise pour uniformiser le goût
le vin est alors industrialisés pour
plaire au plus grand nombre
londres new york montréal primeurs qui
un son rôle de vin de messe profane avec
son goût de bonbon acidulé il fait le
bonheur des anglo saxons ce vin au goût
de banane va donc tout seul construire
sa mauvaise réputation et à partir des
années 2000 les ventes vont s'effondrer
le poggio les nouveaux ne fait plus
recette
il rime avec piquette en 2016 un ancien
vigneron revenait sur cette euphorie aux
jeux vendus au départ dans la période
euphorique égard il n'est pas monté les
juges ont dû les citernes au téléphone
c'est bien jamais personne n'avait goûté
mac os c'est parti en allemagne les pots
cassés car la mauvaise réputation du
beaujolais nouveau avec la boue c'est
toute la région
aujourd'hui les vignerons ont donc une
nouvelle mission nettoyer l'image et la
réputation du beaujolais nouveau et
mettre en valeur les autres crus de la
région
[Musique]